[Music]
and we're doing action just swallow it
in panties in a wad news emitted by
peach tea I'm sorry people candy in her
mouth before she said anything we [ __ ]
up tip tricks us she's like okay
everyone's eating hide she's cool
countdown three two one eating too chewy
the chewy a thing on the planet it's
cause I chew and Victoria's Secret has
come under fire after saying they don't
want plus-sized or trans women walking
the runway what the [ __ ] don't prefer
don't like what want one right you know
and how do you come out saying some [ __ ]
like that
we okay how did they say it alright so
this was an inner No in an interview
this happen in vogue and a chief
marketing officer he said this and I'm
just gonna tell you verbatim and you
could do with it or - we'll all right so
he said I think we address the way the
market is shifting on a constant basis
if you're asking if we've considered
putting a transgender model in the show
or looked at putting a plus-size model
in the show we have we invented the
plus-size model show in what was our
sister Division Lane Bryant Lane Bryant
oh [ __ ] yeah lamebrains dosa sells plus
size lingerie but it's still but it
sells a specific range just like every
specialty retailer in the world sells a
range of clothing as do we we market to
who we sell to and we don't market to
the whole world so that's the specific
thing on the whole what's wrong with us
well I'm fine I mean I was waiting for
him to say and by the way we don't want
any [ __ ] like you know
with you guys but you know people gotta
get at something
weirdest directly say the trans part
yeah ya know what I'm saying let me say
this then people are mad because they're
like you don't have plus-size models in
your Victoria's Secret thing and they
were like okay well let's open up an
entire brand dedicated did like how is
that not better yeah yeah wait where
what about the trans thing well I read
it I mean they said that they've
considered putting a trans well I think
what a lot of these people too aren't
considering is is it's just it's pretty
hard to like have one company that
specializes in everything so they're
saying that they're not a department
store like that would be exactly because
it's really hard to us who we have you
know we have barbell brigade apparel
it's so costly like not that we're like
big in any sort of way but like it's
just so expensive to try to heat it to
every single person but a lot of trans
women look like like it just looks like
Victoria's Secret models like I've seen
like some really hot trans ladies like I
don't understand that that one yeah I
don't I don't get that because he didn't
even say anything about you shopping
they would be shopping dude I bet you
they yo if I if I transitioned like if I
was like male to female and I got like a
fresh pair of hot titties first place
I'm going is Victoria's Secret first
place I'm going but even like
natural-born women who are super hot Sun
with them don't make ends meet or secret
more like it for me I'm not gonna hire
you just for a diversity hire just to
make it exactly what he was saying -
yeah he was saying he was saying like
you know he was saying this another
quote I don't think we can be all things
to all customers at the specialty
business it isn't a department store I'm
always asking myself if we do that what
is the reason we did it why did we
include that person and did we include
them to shut up a reporter did we
include them because it was the right
thing to do or because it was a
politically correct thing to do we so
I'm curious if they had like auditions
for these Victoria's Secret models and a
trans woman auditioned and then they
found out later that she was trans and
then they were like no were they like
nah yeah exactly
that would be [ __ ] up I'm sure like I
think I read somewhere he's they said
that there were trans women who came and
tried out but just simply didn't make it
like not everyone's gonna make it you
know like you model and you don't have
everything exactly like I used to give a
[ __ ] to when I had my agency people like
I would put casting calls I want 511
white girl no tattoos and like Asian
five foot four tattoos be like why don't
you [ __ ] include everyone
yeah my client doesn't want that [ __ ]
everyone it wants a specific look and
then you can't give me [ __ ] for it cuz
you're not paying my bills
you know what taco place like give me a
burger it's hard you don't [ __ ] make
burgers it's hard because I can I can
see both sides of the story right
because I own a business I can see it
from the manufacturing in or the
branding in or whatever and so I
understand where they're coming from but
also from that like where it's like all
the ever one or white tall girls or
whatever then it's like [ __ ] that kind
of sucks two of those you ever seen a
brandy melville is Sarah oh my oh my god
brandy melville it's like all the same
looking model the intact like it's all
disappointing that is but they got a lot
of flack for it right so that's what I'm
saying like that's the only thing to
we're like stuff like that like oh I'm
mad because you don't have like a black
girl or an Asian girl I'm like why are
people getting mad on my behalf I still
shop at brandy melville like like what
the [ __ ] I remember like I get so mad
about that stuff I remember some girl
yelling at shane dawson she was like I
can't believe you would make a pup oh I
can't believe you would make a whole
documentary supporting erases I was like
hold on why are you getting mad on my
behalf like that's I whose erases oh my
gosh every sorry no it was Jay Paul it
was Jay Paul like like I don't know
everyone's been a pic one person that I
don't know how it's gonna end but the
outrage [ __ ] has to stop like
cuz then like the real issues they get
covered they do a lot of sound
everyone's argument doesn't work anymore
I don't know it's it's a tough place to
be because I I get both sides yeah yeah
like you have to you have to bring up a
problem in order to make this problem
change right but then I think the way
that people are going about it is really
[ __ ] up with our like you suck you
suck and it's like we all know that
everyone but you like your dollar is
your biggest foe like if you don't like
something cool don't waste your time
don't talk [ __ ] about it what just go
somewhere else you know what I mean like
don't if you're not if you don't believe
in their values then go to a company
that you believe in their core values
and you're like [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna make
this company blow yeah that's a really
good point it moves me as a trans woman
I want to I wouldn't want to be known as
oh they only hired her because it was
they had to for you know like I want to
earn that [ __ ] exactly I would care
though like you might was that I think
I'd be like [ __ ] it I'm a presentation
yeah I'm gonna get it to any door I can
get into right now and make a [ __ ]
statement you know I mean like there's
two sides they're sure they're like I
don't want to be that example of like
that pity because people people said
that I don't look Filipino so but I look
latina
so that I should act more latina so that
I could get into that niche yeah like I
should learn Spanish and do all that
stuff cuz I get so many more roles if I
wasn't you know but I'm like well I'm
not latina yeah yeah but yeah but I
would be it's like that like oh if you
were this this is what everyone need is
trying to hire right now yeah so be that
and then you could get in there's a
small progress there's like I mean it
throughout the modeling world the first
black super fat or super model there's
like the world's or I mean Victoria's
first Filipino angel like this about the
black ballerina like ice-t uh what's her
last name
misty you know okay well the first black
ballerina I can't remember her last name
I'm blanking off but misty like everyone
knows that ballet is like super white
you know what I mean like like they want
that white specific look and she was
just like nah [ __ ] that like I'm
passionate about this the ballerinas
that dance like hip-hop and stuff yeah
so pretty though yeah
yeah but that's like the super it's like
golf you know what I mean where it's
like super traditional and you stick to
this thing and it's super conventional
but I think I think it it that's why I'm
like kind of torn like I don't like that
everyone wants to make everything be for
everyone I think that's [ __ ] up
because I'm just like that's just not
realistic and you don't want like if you
go to a bail argument is like I don't
see color like the same thing yes you do
everyone is just like one thing or like
everyone should get a trophy everyone
everyone should win yeah that's a that's
a so he sucks at soccer I want to get
one [ __ ] trophy for also like I've
been in a position before where I felt
like I was a demographic charity case
and it's not fun like it's really not it
makes you doubt your own abilities so
like and so like how do you feel knowing
that people are like saying like you
have to include us you have to okay fine
come on well does that it like now you
finally get it but then you step back
and realize like I didn't really earn
this you know like I wanted okay fine
come on yeah like I want you to walk my
runway you want to be loved and
appreciated for you and your talents not
just what you represent
like that's why I wonder if a trans
woman was killing it that hard like if
Victoria Secret be like oh we want you
you know like and then it's like because
is it is it that they're just saying no
trans women or is that the them found
the watch exactly that and they that
that that's more I don't know that's
that's easier to understand I guess okay
that's the case here I also don't like
the headline that was drawn out it was
like they don't want any of you but then
we read the statement and it's like he's
trying to like they have a stance and
now it's this guy's like job to
communicate that stance and they're
still like what headline can we take out
of that like yeah they just want to
create drama and I hate that I heard you
step down
oh it's actually a CEO that step down
this is a CMO Oh are there any women on
this board
okay yeah um they were just saying cuz
of like a pressures and subbing oh
that's tough yeah right well I feel like
the company it's pretty shitty though I
mean like Victoria's Secret has been
like on a steady decline for about ten
you're like for a decade now in what way
though his Chitti who do you really go
to Victoria shop there anymore like I
stopped doing that in high school yeah
it was hot when you're in high school
you're like oh I'm buying my real
laundry and now women are more going
towards comfort rather than sexy okay
yeah yeah well in also did you know that
they have the same middle person
manufacturers Target so like the bras at
Target and get all my [ __ ] from Target
babe underwear
they're all mine it's five for 20 bucks
oh yeah hey dude oh yeah yeah I don't
have like it's not seem so like it's
just nice and like seamless damn
Victoria sticker what happened dude but
see you Millennials are killing him
they have targeted his fashion is really
not it's kind of it's a very interesting
market isn't it's kind of there's things
that you don't want to hear about it for
instance there's no luxury stores in the
Midwest because they literally do not
want you wearing that in the Midwest
like they want fashionable people out in
the coast if you look at the brands and
stuff in their locations there's none in
[ __ ] Kentucky or anything anything
they want to buy it to buy online so
it's like this is fashion you're not
gonna include everyone in it that's just
the fact of the matter
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]